[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact hermit crabs are comical
looking crustaceans found around the
world
however unlike crabs lobsters and shrimp
hermit crabs are born with no
exoskeletons on their soft abdomens this
leaves them vulnerable to predators so
to survive hermit crabs must scavenge
for abandoned shells of various snails
when they find one that fits they tucked
themselves inside for protection and
carry it with them wherever they go
there are over a thousand different
kinds of hermit crabs some live in the
sea others on land hermit crabs get
their name because they live in borrowed
shells but in reality they're very
social creatures that enjoy living in
large groups some groups up to a hundred
as hermit crabs outgrow their shelves
they have to go shopping for a new one
during this time they can be very fussy
about the new shell they choose they
want a strong shell with a little
growing room so they can fully retreat
into it when threatened when a new
larger shell becomes available several
hermit crabs will sometimes form a line
by hit from the largest to the smallest
and they play a serious game of musical
chairs all furiously scrambling to
upgrade their shells at the same time
for an extra layer of protection some
ocean-going hermit crabs like to
decorate their shelves with cien enemies
this helps with camouflage not to
mention that an enemies are poisonous so
other creatures usually leave the hermit
crab alone while most hermit crabs are
small some as small as a grain of rice
one species of hermit crab holds the
title as the largest land dwelling
crustacean in the world the coconut crab
or the robber crab living in the indian
ocean can grow to spread over three feet
weigh more than nine pounds and live up
to 60
years in the wild it's been estimated
that some hermit crabs will change their
shells as many as 90 times over the
course of their life it must be tough to
have to move so frequently you know the
Bible talks about a people that stayed
on the move for forty years
stay with his friends were going to
learn more as amazing thanks brings you
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
thats 1-800 four six three seventy to
ninety seven now let's join our host
pastor doug batchelor welcome friends do
Bible answers live and if you're tuning
in for the first time this is a live
international interactive Bible study
and you are invited to participate give
us a call with your Bible questions
here's the number 800 God says we've got
phone lines open right now so call with
your question good chance we'll be able
to address that on tonight's program for
Bible questions give us a call
here's the number again 800 four six
three seven two nine seven get your
pencil give it to you one more time
800 four six three seven 297 my name is
Doug Batchelor pastor John Ross is on
the road this weekend and so with the
help of our team here we're gonna fly
solo so let's start the program with the
word of Prayer
loving Lord we just thank you again for
the blessing we have in the Bible and we
just pray that your presence will be
here take charge of this program and we
ask that the people that call in will
hear the Holy Spirit's speaking to them
through the holy book we thank you and
ask this in Jesus name Amen well friends
I was fascinated by what I was reading
about hermit crabs and I've traveled a
lot and seen them in the Pacific and
Caribbean and they are they are comical
they're fun and curious little creatures
to watch both underwater and you see
them on land and that's fun how you see
them quickly retreat into their shells
when you pick them up
and then they sometimes fight with each
other over you'll see two or three
hermit crabs fighting with each other
over a new vacant shell that they found
and so they're a lot of fun to watch
some people get them as pets because
they'll keep the aquarium clean they eat
the algae but constantly moving and
upgrading and changing houses well in
this last year mrs. bachelor and I have
moved and it is stressful to move to a
new home I can't imagine what it would
be like to move 90 times over the course
of your life but you know the Bible
talks about a people that we're really a
nation on the move and of course you
know we're talking about the children of
Israel because they did not have enough
faith right away God said that they were
gonna have to wander for forty years in
the wilderness and they'd say some
places for a few weeks sometimes as long
as a year God's Way he would say then
pack up we're moving to a new spot and
they moved and moved and moved over a
period of 40 years but God took care of
them the whole time they were moving and
God will take care of you as you journey
through life you can read in Deuteronomy
2 verse 7 for the Lord your God has
blessed you in all the work of your hand
he knows about your trudging through
this great wilderness these 40 years the
Lord your God has been with you and you
have lacked nothing through all their
wanderings God wandered with them and he
took care of them and when the Lord
directs you from one place to another
you can be sure that the will of God
will never lead you where the grace of
God is not going to supply and keep you
and so we have a special offer we'd like
to share with you and it talks about the
children of Israel and how we can apply
some lessons that we've learned from
ancient Israel to the church today
you'll really enjoy this it's called
spiritual Israel written by myself and
pastor Steve Walberg and if you'd like a
free copy of this book we will send it
to you it's free under the condition you
do read it and the chair with a friend
here's the number for the free resource
now this is a different number from the
callin number you ready
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven to get your free copy of
spiritual Israel eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven still
see a couple of lines open if you have a
Bible related question
or a question on living the Christian
life that number is 864-226-7222 house
down on himself in the philistines it so
you could call it a suicide and so you
know it is a it's a very difficult
subject in as a pastor I've had to do
funeral services before for people that
took their own lives and it it's can be
very challenging but you know we just
got to know that the Lord loves people
infinitely more than we do and the Lord
is going to do all that he can to save
as many as he can but
I also want to make it clear because if
there's people out there thinking well
I'm 20 with the idea of suicide because
my life is so difficult that's a bad
idea because when you commit suicide
you'll lose all of your options when
you're alive the Bible says a living dog
is better than a dead lion and your
circumstances could turn for the better
in a day and God gives us grace one day
at a time
and who knows what you're gonna miss if
you were to check out so to speak so you
know and some people think I'm going to
improve my circumstances by committing
suicide if the Bible is true and I
believe it is the lost person's next
conscious thought is waking up in the
great Judgment and facing the lake of
fire
so how suicide would improve their
circumstances that's a lie
so I know that's a long convoluted
answer Jim I hope some of it made sense
and did you have it did that register
okay yeah just you know I was kind of
close friend its Kent yeah it's
heartbreaking isn't it yeah yeah so does
I put it in God's hands you know we
don't know we we just have to put it in
God's can so we don't know what that
future means and just know the Lord
loves your friend infinitely more than
you do and he is also a just God
I appreciate your call by the way I do
have an article where I talk about
suicide at the amazing facts website you
can just do a search there on the word
suicide go to amazing facts dot o-r-g
appreciate your call speaking next with
Alan who's calling from Scottsdale
Arizona Alan you're on the air with
Bible answers live hello pastor I'm
talking about John 3:5 and 6 and using
the idea of parallelism except a man be
born of water in five corresponds to
that which is born of flesh is flesh in
six and of spirit in five is born of the
Spirit is spirit and so that's B
born of water is not water baptism is it
well I think it is now tell you why if
you're ready for me to share that with
you I'm ready
the whole emphasis in the beginning of
John's Gospel he's talking about John
the Baptist first couple of chapters if
Jesus said unless you're born of the
water in the spirit and he didn't mean
baptism some people thought well you
know babies in an envelope of water
before it's born and so maybe Jesus is
saying unless you're born of the human
birth and the spiritual birth but then
you have to ask why would Jesus say that
because that would be the same as saying
unless you're born of a woman and born
of the Spirit you can't well everybody's
born of a woman the reason I think Jesus
is saying unless you're born of the
water meaning you choose to commit your
life to the Lord and be washed and born
of the Spirit is God's choice and keep
in mind the last thing Jesus says as he
sends out his disciples is go and teach
baptize in the name of the Father Son
and Holy Spirit and in mark 16 he says
whoever believes in his Baptizer baptism
was a priority to Jesus because it's in
his closing address and so I think
Christ is saying unless you commit your
life to the Lord
baptism is as important to a Christian
as a wedding is to a marriage it's the
moment when it becomes a covenant and so
I think he's saying you need to make a
covenant born of the water and God will
then promise you the spirit now when
Jesus was baptized he went out of the
water and the Holy Spirit came down he's
born of the water born of the Spirit the
children of Israel who we were talking
about a minute ago when they came out of
the wilderness that the Bible says that
they went through the Red Sea born of
the water and that's 1st Corinthians 10
and the pillar of fire came down born of
the Spirit they were born in the sea and
in the cloud fire water baptism so I
think that this is what John is talking
about but you know I have a book on that
I'll be happy to send you a free copy
Alan and it's baptism isn't necessary if
you call the resource number which is
883 five six seven four seven
you're listening to Bible answers live
and we've offered you that free book on
baptism is it necessary that we'll go
through all these verses and I think
you'll really be blessed by that
appreciate your call very much and with
that we do open up another phone line if
you have a Bible question eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven
gonna talk next to Paul Mar calling from
Riverside California am I saying that
right Pilar thank you so much for taking
my question I just wanted to find out
about this system of Thailand it's kind
of new to me I hear you are claiming
federal taxes I'm tired and I just
wonder that it's biblical and if so how
well the the provisions that are made in
the taxes regarding offerings whether
it's tithe or offering if you're giving
to a an organization a nonprofit
organization the government actually and
it's a very old law they're saying that
that you have made a commitment to
something that is out of your house to a
humanitarian purpose it doesn't need to
be a church it could be in an orphanage
it could be it could be an atheist and
you could give to the nonprofit ASPCA
but if you're giving to something
outside of your help they're not going
to count that as your income and they
give you a credit for it so there's
nothing wrong there's no moral problem
with taking advantage of the legal
accounting that the government does for
nonprofit donations there's no moral
challenge to doing that it's a
government law and the idea was the
government did not want to tax and some
countries are different in America is
one of the most generous countries in
the world with charitable organizations
because of our laws I've been to
countries where the people say you know
we get taxed so heavily that the
government takes it before I can give to
a charity so Americans say what does it
matter to you you tithe or offerings so
are you saying well are you asking if
your you're supposed to tithe on your
tax income tax return yeah you're in
turn when you're you're claiming your
income tax return and you're putting
tithing on that no I'll tell you I I
wouldn't think you would need to because
if you're paying tithes you get your
income through the year when you get a
tax return you've already paid on that
that's your income you've already paid
on so you'd be paying twice on it now
you know there's no problem if you want
to try and pay an extra tithe but if you
pay tithe on your income when you first
get it and in other words the gross of
your income then when you get your tax
return you've already paid tithes on it
if you're only paying income on the net
you're not counting for what the
government's taking then when you get
your tax return it's a new income then
you'd pay taxes on it so the idea of
tithe is your pain on your increase is
the principle now did that make sense
what I wanted to find out when you're
doing your tax return some people put
the time and the receipts from your
church on that and they're saying you
could get that tax return from that so
I'm wondering if that is correct if
you're giving to God your tithe you're
returning to time why would you want to
get it back well you're not getting it
back what you're doing is you're getting
the government gives you credit for
donations to charities tithes would be
this is what I was telling you the first
time tithe is part of a donation to a
charity you know I I have a lesson that
deals with that we'll send you a free
copy up amar it's called In God We Trust
it's got a whole Bible study with all
the scripture references on the subject
of tithe and offerings and I think your
questions addressed in there so yeah
you're just claiming the deduction and
there's nothing wrong with that hey
thank you very much we appreciate your
call and hope that helps a little bit
and that does open another line again if
you have a Bible question 800 for six
three seven two nine seven brings your
question into the studio that's 800 four
six three seven two nine seven and lines
are open gonna talk next to Ray who's
calling from Burlingame California ray
on the air with Bible answers live that
can you hear me okay loud and clear
yeah what I asked you and your in your
opinion why um there's a gigantic surge
in the predestination part you know that
Calvin taught and all that you know I'm
not saying denominations but it seems
everywhere now you looked at weird if
you don't believe that but I don't see
in the Bible most that well I'm with you
I don't see it in the Bible and you know
most of the great Protestant preachers
you talk about you know Wesley and
Luther and many others they did not
believe that once you're saved you could
not be lost they did believe that if you
live in faith you could have assurance
if you walk with God there there are
promises in the Bible that if you
continue
that's what Paul said all the time he
says faith is something that must be
nurtured you must continue in it Peter
talks about the dog that returns to his
vomit and the pig that was washed to
wallowing in the mire and in Hebrews it
talks about you know if a person was
enlightened and has tasted of the
heavenly gift and they turn away people
that were Judaizers that believed in
Jesus but then you're going back
sacrificial stuff that would be
unforgivable you know I've seen
otherwise we're all going to hell
because we sin on purpose no such a
thing so you believe you believe that a
person can be saved but then they have
to nurture that relationship to maintain
salvation you can't be saved once except
the Lord and then you can turn back the
world and still be said no I mean it's
it's through God but I can't do nothing
because even Peter said you kept by the
power God if I have to do it all there's
everybody's going to hell because what's
enough you don't know if you did enough
or well there is something I need to do
that what separates the state or the
lost is something you do and what that
is that's well no that's right but
that's what I'm saying
believing in the Lord trusting in him
repenting of your sins there so that's
something you need to do but Paul said I
died I
they die daily in other words everyday
yeah we need to renew all things you
don't want to do he does anyway indebted
I never said he cut that out either
necessarily I mean it just depends but I
mean I'm just saying it's not by our
trying no man is a no man made rights of
deserving to the law that's what problem
with some of these denominations they go
by the law and they did there's no
gospel it's a lie because they either
Christ dinner he didn't do it he can't
halfway do it he's got it do it totally
it's either senator named just like a
Catholic they do the math over and over
and over that's blasphemous yeah we made
it perfect but no they don't believe
that we are saved entirely by grace
through faith but when we are saved
we'll want to do everything we can
humanly do to follow God and you know
Paul said that even for the Christian
there is wrestling there's running
there's fighting they're striving there
there is the idea that there's no effort
to surrender I mean the greatest battle
that Jesus fought was in the Garden of
Gethsemane when he said not my will
thigh will be done
and everyday Christians have to say I'm
going to be crucified with Christ and
there's a struggle in there and you say
no not my will thigh will be done so our
struggle is to trust him and surrender
to Him on a daily basis and then the
Lord you know he gives us the power but
we need to keep placing our will in his
hands and you know I do have a book if
you like a free copy that talks about a
salvation and assurance and it deals
with the once saved always saved and the
relationship between law and grace
matter of fact I have a study that talks
about does God's grace blot out the law
and you I think really appreciate that
we'll send you a free copy just call 808
three five six seven four seven eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and we do have another line open I
like to just keep people lined up so
that we have lots of phone calls coming
in and we'll get to your questions at
that number again 804 63 72 97 with your
Bible questions
appreciate your call very much ray and
without we're talking to sorrow
who's calling from Brooklyn New York
Saro you're on the air with Bible
answers live now they wanted to talk to
you for a long time because you know a
few weeks ago you are talking about you
know that loving God with not true
people in entire and some people having
difficulty understanding that you know
well no I do believe you may have
misunderstood me
I do believe there's a lake of fire and
I do believe a loving God will send the
wicked to the lake of fire the Bible is
very clear and revelation about that so
what you may have heard me say is I
don't believe that he tortures them for
eternity for the sins of one lifetime so
according to the Bible it says the
wicked are consumed their burnt up their
ashes they perish they're destroyed the
language in the Bible is pretty clear
that God makes all things new and
there's no more pain and so yeah so I
believe there's a lake of fire and I'll
send you we have a lesson on that that
explains you know they had some churches
don't believe that the wicked are gonna
suffer at all some believe in
universalism that everyone will be saved
some believe in what you call
annihilationism which means that there
is punishment there is a lake of fire
but the Scriptures where they say that
you burn for you know 10 million years
and you stick your head out of the
sulfur and you're still burning and
you've not even begun after 10 billion
years a zillion years you're still
burning that I don't believe a lot of
people from the dead so we have to
assume that God is not so he was so much
that he will only bring back the bad
people put them in the fire and if his
own people on the ground so if he said
that he's not going to bring back
everybody so we have to assume that
he'll only bring back his own people and
leave the wicked one on the ground the
wages of sin is what yeah that's it well
no I what
have to respectfully disagree because
when Jesus was being tried he told the
high priest who was a wicked person
hereafter you will see the Son of man
coming in the clouds of heaven so
Caiaphas was going to be resurrected to
see Jesus come again and so though we
all must stand before the judgment seat
of Christ Christ was pretty clear that
there is a Judgment Day and all that are
in the graves will hear his voice and
come forth they that have done good the
resurrection of life they that have done
evil the resurrection of damnation two
resurrections dead in Christ rise first
revelation 20 says the rest of the Dead
live after the 1000 years their wicked
are clearly coming out of their graves
and there's a judgment hey but I got a
move on
try and get one more call before the
break sorrow appreciate your call very
much and we do have a lesson that talks
about the lake of fire we'll send you a
free copy it's called is the devil in
charge of Hell is the devil in charge of
hell that resource line if you want a
free copy anybody if you want to
understand this subject eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you will ask for that you'll
hear the good news about Hell that's
called an oxymoron all right with that
how much time we have left
two minutes let me see what I can do in
two minutes gonna talk to Sharon calling
from Yakima Washington Sharon you're on
the air can you hear me yes I can well
let's see if we get started on our
question before the break okay no go
ahead please
okay my question and I know it's been
asked before well I thought it was an
adequate answer why did God create earth
we talked about you know freewill that
seems kind of a selfish I mean you know
from a human point you know standpoint a
way to have people you know choose
freewill to be with the Lord when there
is you know such incredible incredible
beyond belief sorrow in this world yeah
and why would he
why would he create people to suffer so
there would be a select few that could
make the right choice a freewill choice
to be with him alright let me ask you a
couple questions just before we we're
gonna take a break here in a moment
but hey do you believe the Bible is true
as much as I know do you believe God is
love alright well stand by Sharon we're
going to come back to you in just a
moment but I I want to be able to get to
your question it's a very important
question a lot of people think if God is
a good God if he's all-powerful why
would he make Lucifer later became Satan
in the devil and couldn't he have
changed that if it was there some
problem in the wiring at the factory did
God make a mistake why would God want to
make a creature that would tempt and
torment and bring all this suffering
into the world that is one of the big
really important questions we're gonna
deal with it in just a moment stay tuned
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control wham you're
hit with something new your marriage is
good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
that job's great and then it's gone and
so's your life savings you feel healthy
Daniel doctor gives the bad news what's
coming next
you could look to the stars but they
don't have the answers but this does the
prophecy Study Bible by amazing facts
this Bible special its 27 personal study
guides leave you on a life-changing
journey from God's Word to discover real
answers to life's questions from health
and relationships
to family and the future the hopes in
here get your amazing facts prophecy
Study Bible today by calling
[Music]
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
phone call 804 63 72 97 my name is Doug
Batchelor pastor John Ross is on the
road tonight and we're going to go back
to a question in our last half we were
just getting a great question from
Sharon that was dealing with a subject
of if God is a loving God why would he
make a devil is that right Sharon people
die because I struggle with that yeah
it's a good question
it's a great question because obviously
if God's powerful and if he knows
everything and if he knew that he was
making this angel that was going to
rebel and become proud and obstinate and
lead a number of others to become proud
and he was going to hijack a world and
why did God just say well look I'm going
to not make that one the greatest
evidence that God is love and that he
gives his creatures freedom to love him
or not love him is what happened with
Lucifer God said I'm not just going to
make creatures that are all that are
robots that automatically say I Love You
God I Love You God he said I'm gonna
make creatures that are
really free moral intelligent creatures
they have to choose if my attributes are
worthy of their love or not and Lucifer
chose to love himself more and he
persuaded one third of the Angels
according to Revelation to follow him
and God could have destroyed Lucifer
with a bolt of lightning as soon as that
happened but he said then the other
angels and creatures will follow me out
of fear and not love so the Lord had to
allow this terrible rebellion and
experiment with sin to play itself out
so that all the creatures would know he
really is a God of love okay and I am
fully understand that and to maybe
possibly interrupt you quickly here when
he knew the suffering though that would
ensue why did he just not stop the
entire process just so he could have a
select few of the free world people to
love him well it's not just about people
in this winter I mean how does he watch
this mad it breaks his heart and that's
why God came into the world he do well
because then God would be a dictator
that forces creatures to love him and if
you don't love him he's going to destroy
you why did he create anyone was he
creep well good it's going to be the
case why do parents do you have any
children Sharon oh but we had children
did you get a guarantee when your
children were born that that they would
be obedient and cooperative so you took
a risk when you chose to have children
that you wanted to love them and you're
hoping they love you that they may not
because they're free yes but God no
everything that he knew that there was
going to be a certain portion of the
population and the people that he
created or allowed he didn't know oh
yeah this terrible suffering and I
want to remind you it bothers and hurts
God more than anybody and with you I've
lost the salad
I mean I know the grief that you're
feeling and it's it's an awful so from
the very very beginning why would he
even start out on this entire you know a
word I'm looking for
want me to go on with the experiment of
making human experiment well because
there are other creatures Sharon that
are throughout the universe besides man
and there's angels and the Bible
indicates that there other unfallen
worlds that God has made that are holy
and they all see that God is love and
through the infinite ages of eternity
when all the saved exists they'll never
question that God is loved because
Christ he's gonna have the scars in his
hands because of the rebellion and
because of what sin did no one will ever
experiment with sin again but he allowed
even creatures to rebel to show that
they're free please let me send you we
have a lesson called did God create a
devil it's right up the alley and you
can read it online just go to amazing
facts ask for the study guide did God
create a devil it's a great study it
shows you the scriptures and you can
even we've got a new video we produced
an amazing facts called cosmic conflict
we'd love for people to order the DVD
it's it dramatizes why there's this
rebellion the whole thing is about your
question Sharon but you can probably
even watch her for free on YouTube right
now if you want to see it right away
everything ends up on YouTube hey but we
need to keep going to some folks that
have been standing by and so we
appreciate your understanding all right
with that we're gonna talk next -
Raymond has been waiting very patiently
Raymond you're on the air with Bible
answers live hey thank you very much
this is actually pastor Doug but that's
okay that's alright pastor Roscoe's on
the road right yeah but a couple weeks
ago he introduced me as pastor Ross so
we get mixed up and your questions right
I think you kind of frame
answer-there Oh with the previous
question previous question my question
was says guys is all annoying why he
created of an even knowing that they
were gonna send and I think you clean
what the answer to my question was the
last caller with yes about Lucifer yeah
just because yes the answer of course is
yes he did no and because they were made
free God showed his love in that he gave
them the choice and then you know the
neat thing is if if Adam and Eve weren't
made in spite of the rebellion you and I
would not exist and we now have an
opportunity to live forever in paradise
with God if we embrace his plan of
salvation so in spite of the terrible
things that have happened I'm thankful
that I exist first if I didn't I would
never know that I wasn't thankful
is nice to be here anyway Raymond hey
please take a look at that cosmic
conflict video you can either order a
copy of amazing facts or watch it on
YouTube cosmic conflict just type that
in it'll come up appreciate your call
with that we're gonna talk to Kevin
who's calling from Palm Springs
California Kevin you're on the air with
Bible answers live doing great cremation
wrong well I know I was cremated and she
was a lady of faith and her mom wasn't
but I mean I guess it's a choice but
I've always said if you your hearts with
the Lord you draw your last breath your
your souls with him rest oh it's just a
shell I mean but I've heard people say
that you should be cremated that's the
will let's talk about that Wow
let's talk about that for just a moment
you know a lot of Christians lost their
lives at one of the many persecutions in
history whether it was the Inquisition
or or one of the other battles or purges
that happen some were burnt at the stake
faithful Christians they died singing
praying burn at the stake for their
faith even Isis has not only beheaded
people but I
has burned some alive now if you're
Christian and you're burnt
is that gonna prevent God from creating
a new person not at all because when the
Lord comes back he's not looking for the
old parts he's not reassembling and he's
not going to come down and say wow that
person died at sea and they've been
eaten by the fish where am I going to
find all the pieces to put them back
together
of course nothing's too hard for the
Lord but that's not you know that's not
the issue God is going to create a new
person and we have glorified bodies if
we're alive when the Lord comes were
transformed to a new body so typically
in the Bible people were buried but
there were also a couple of cases of
people that were burnt Jonathan who was
a godly man a hero in the Bible he was
killed by the Philistines and later the
men of jabish Gilead they rescued his
body and they cremated it well I'm sure
Jonathan's going to be in heaven so
typically in the Bible they were buried
a cremation is a lot more cost-effective
but I don't think there's any Bible law
no commandment where it says that's the
way she choose but I was you answered my
question that was in my mind though I
like to get my ask around that's good
when tells us a multitude of counselors
their safety all right when you drive
through Palm Springs look up at that
mountain I used to live in a cave up
there so far so Road and there's a
church out here and there's a cross
right on top of a mountain at the top of
that church and you can just let up at
night yeah beautiful landmark hey thank
you very much Kevin appreciate your call
and I hope you give us a call again
alright we're gonna talk next with let
me see here phil has been waiting
patiently Phil you're on the air with
Bible answers live no I hit the wrong
London
Phil you're on the air with Bible
answers live I do now
great my question is what do you think
ever happened to the Ark of the Covenant
you think it's been destroyed you think
it's intact do you think it if so you
think he could ever resurface yeah well
I tell you what I believe is if you look
in the Bible the Ark of the Covenant is
mentioned shortly before the children of
Israel are carried away captive to
Babylon Jeremiah told the King Zedekiah
the Babylonians are going to break
through the wall they were besieged
they're going to destroy the temple and
he said you need to surrender well
Zedekiah wasn't gonna surrender and so
it's believed that Jeremiah and some of
the priests they took the ark before
Nebuchadnezzar they knew a few days
before he broke through that it was
hopeless they hid it in a cave somewhere
in the probably the end there underneath
Jerusalem and I've been there it's just
honeycombed with caves they buried it in
a cave and sealed it off and I don't
think it's ever been found
because when Nebuchadnezzar did conquer
Jerusalem it itemizes the articles they
took from the temple but it never
mentions the ark because York was gone
at that point but the ark was there up
until Nebuchadnezzar so it's pretty
clear that Jeremiah and some of the
other priests they hid the ark to keep
it from falling into pagan hands there's
nothing in the Bible that says it went
with Solomon down to the Queen of Sheba
that's one rumor but years later you
find out it's still in the sanctuary in
the days of Hezekiah it mentions it
specifically so that I think is the best
will it surface again I don't know it'd
be wonderful if it did if anyone had any
doubts about the ten commandments that
would probably settle the issue so yeah
be neat if they would find it but you
know they're doing all kinds of
excavation around Jerusalem who knows
it's dangerous if they found the Ark of
the Covenant no if they well I know that
they're doing some excavation on
underneath the sanctuary I've got a
friend that just returned last week and
they found some of the original
foundation stones from the days of
Solomon and they got one stone that
weighed more than a loaded 747 one stone
in the temple they were huge
anyway he filled that's a great question
and you know I I don't know exactly
where the Ark is hidden but I know what
was in the Ark and I've got it in my
Bible it's called the ten commandments
and we have a lesson that talks about
that and if you'd like a free copy it's
called written in stone written in stone
we'll send that to you just call 808
three five six seven four seven now I'm
gonna jump back I just rudely had picked
up on Joshua and then hung up again
Joshua are you there yes I am thanks how
you doing you're on the air great what
do you think you know we have different
denominations and stuff where do you
think doctrinal distinction can be okay
with denomination but then there's a
line to draw to where somebody is
outside of the Christian faith a debate
right with baptism and all that kind of
stuff we can all debate those things but
the essentials is Christ with faith
through grace right not of works and all
that but then there's other people who
embrace who don't embrace the doctrine
of hell or don't embrace the doctrine of
original sin or that they can earn their
salvation with grace you know
semi-pelagianism and stuff that
augustine battled and so how do you draw
the line between what is tolerable
differences and differences are
non-negotiable yes well you know I think
that the the fundamentals of
Christianity are believing in the
inspiration of the word because as soon
as someone starts doubting that they you
know they believe in evolution and in
all kinds of heresies believing in the
divinity of Christ Jesus was not just a
good man or prophet and and you know
that we are say
by grace through faith because you don't
want to corrupt salvation by works which
is you know the antithesis of salvation
now having said that you know and I
can't obviously you could go through
about 60 different nuances of doctrine
having said that I want to make it clear
while I respectfully disagree with my
friends that are Roman Catholics I
believe I'm gonna see plenty of
Catholics in heaven I think that you
know they're just there's a lot of very
dear sacrificial people they love the
Lord they surrendered to him they trust
by faith in God but you know they're
mixed up on the role of the church and
the Pope and the priests and a lot of
issues we disagree with and what one
reason I say that is you look in the Old
Testament God winked at the ignorance of
some of the patriarchs that had multiple
wives now today if a church is teaching
you can have multiple wives we'd call
that a heresy but you know they live in
a time back then when they just didn't
know you know what I'm saying all right
I've got pretty strong beliefs about
drinking alcohol I think it's a drug
it's more deadly than any drug but I
know there's gonna be good Christians
that disagree with me on that and you
know and I'm gonna see them in the
kingdom if they they live by faith and
they trust in the Lord man looks on the
outward appearance God looks on the
heart and the Lord knows if a person is
fully surrendered to him so I think
we've got it some surprises when we get
to heaven someone said this three
surprises one surprises that were there
the other surprise is there's gonna be
people there that we didn't expect to
see in the third surprise is it going to
be people missing we thought would be
front and center so you know yeah that's
I think it's gonna be interesting when
Steven gets to heaven he sees the
Apostle Paul there yeah you know what I
mean anyway hey appreciate your question
hope that helps a little bit and we'll
appreciate your patience also that does
free up another line and we've
we have time for you to call in with
your Bible question before we close one
more time here's the number eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven gonna talk next to II Frank who's
calling from a story in New York you
Frank you're on the air yes nice to
speak to you again pastor Doug like my
question for you my question for you
tonight is can pastors or church leaders
lead you to enter into understanding the
biblical standing or the biblical
meaning of what salvation is because I
had to be forced in my local church to
be an operational committee chairman to
help a local 19th century priest named
Reverend Father I'm sorry I had to say
father reverend current from 1841 who
founded a church here locally and he
insisted that people can be saved only
by works and through worshipping
scripture and some dogmatic
understanding of what Christianity is he
would actually go on ferries to convert
people with the Holy Bible do you think
that's the proper way to actually accept
salvation or is this just a prospect
that you go through in time no I would
respectfully disagree with what you said
he was saying you know I think that
pastors can be the vehicle to salvation
in that it's through the proclamation of
the word when people learn about the
goodness of God through the gospel the
goodness of God in Jesus it leads us to
repentance and we love Him because we
see through the proclamation of the word
that he first loved us and so as pastors
or anybody doesn't have to be a pastor
he's sharing the word they can be a
vehicle through which the Lord reveals
truth and a person has led to salvation
it's not through the book with the
letters in it it's not that the Bible is
some kind of sacred Oracle it's not a
good luck charm or something like that
it's through the message that changes
hearts through the preaching of the word
but Jesus said the words that I speak
they are spirit and they are life and so
that's what brings people salvation hey
thank you Frank I hope that helps a
little bit and with that we're going to
be talking to Angelica
who's calling from Bushkill Pennsylvania
Angelica you're on the air um you know I
have a problem I found you know you know
forgiving myself or something that I did
you know in my in my youth you know I
grew up in the church and you know for
my other child and you know when I were
in my 20s I you know at a back spit and
you know I I you know I had an abortion
and didn't understand what I was doing
at the time and you know I've just been
battling with some forgiving myself I
you know I know that God you know I
asked me to forgive me but I have to
forgive my sin and I believe that he has
but you know I'm just having problems
I'm trying to forgive yourself yeah well
I'll tell you what there's a statement
where Jesus talks about the unpardonable
sin and everybody wonders what that is
but let me tell you what he says before
he talks about it all manner of sin and
blasphemy will be forgiven under the
children of men all manner and nowhere
does the Bible say that abortion is the
unforgivable sin which means that it is
among the forgivable sins and I'm quite
sure that whenever we confess our sins
and repent that God will forgive us
there is a king in the Bible and I hope
you'll even pardon the analogy but there
was a king in the Bible that offered his
children as sacrifices so you would say
he was guilty of infanticide his name is
Manasseh he repented and God forgave him
and heard his prayer and he actually
sacrificed several children he also
killed the prophet Isaiah to say I mean
he was a bad guy but you know obviously
the Holy Spirit has spoken to you you
you're sorry
you can
you've repented now you need to believe
the Lord says if we are confess if we
repent he is faithful and just to
forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness now if he's
cleansing us from all unrighteousness
and by the way that's 1st John chapter 1
verse 9 if he cleanses us from all
unrighteousness
then were cleansed and you needed us
thank him for that and you know it
doesn't mean the devil's not gonna
remind you I mean I've asked God to
forgive me for things I know he's
forgiven me the devil still brings him
back to my mind and I kind of you know I
grit my teeth and say oh what was I
doing and then I remember Jesus forgave
me it's under the blood and you need to
believe that - Angelica you mean like an
aborted baby yeah
well the Bible tells us there are going
to be children there and I want to be a
bit surprised if when you're in the
resurrection or if you're alive when the
Lord comes if you don't experience
angels bringing that child to you and so
you know don't you worry I promise I
promise you're gonna be happy when you
see Jesus and you will not be
disappointed let me have prayer with you
real quick if that be ok Angelica yeah
father in heaven I just pray you'll be
with my dear sister and Lord I know she
represents hundreds if not thousands
others like her out there but we're
deceived by the culture and made a
terrible mistake and she's sorry lord
help her to just experience your grace
and mercy and forgiveness and know
you're a loving God and remind her that
the new birth is just that that she is
also born again and becomes a new
creature with a new beginning and so
bless her with that now I pray in Jesus
name Amen
all right Angelica and you know we have
a lesson that deals with the subject of
salvation that God's love is still there
if you call our resource line we'll send
your FREE copy of that you can even read
it right now online about his love still
being there and just go to amazing facts
dot o-r-g alright I think we're gonna
try and take oh let's see here
kay has been waiting in San Luis Obispo
okay you have a question yes thank you
for that prayer with that lady that's
really touched me thank you I know many
others were joining me in prayer for her
yes I listen to you Addison your Sabbath
classes and your TV programs and ninety
percent I agree with you but when I read
zechariah 14 like verses 16 and on you
know talks about holy days that Jesus
kept and Paul kept after Jesus why is it
that you know you don't why I don't
believe in keeping the Jewish feast days
yes because you know Jesus kept it you
just kept the Sabbath you just kept the
holy days in Paul kept it well right
let's let me just before we run out of
time I want to try and give you some
answer just because Jesus did something
does not mean it's a law for all
Christians Jesus was also what let me
let me let me finish prisons Jesus was
also circumcised and there's nothing
wrong if someone wants to be but the
Bible is pretty clear that it's not
required
for a Christian to be circumcised at
Paul you read Paul says circumcision is
nothing uncircumcision is nothing
keeping the commandments is what matters
so we believe that the ceremonial laws
they were nailed to the cross and you
read about that in Colossians chapter 2
the Bible tells us in second Corinthians
that Christ is our Passover which is
offered for us and so to keep the Old
Testament feasts it's a whole different
category than the Ten Commandments and I
you know if someone wants to they're
fine but they shouldn't mandate it for
others they all pointed to Jesus Jesus
came by embracing Jesus it's much more
than the feast and we don't sacrifice
lambs anymore Oh whole friends were out
of time if we didn't get to your
question tonight I apologize give us
another chance God willing we're going
to be back again next week and
so much more than we offer just take a
look at amazing facts dot o-r-g 24 hours
a day there's programming there and if
you enjoyed the program keep us on the
line and donate
god bless thank you for listening to
today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history landmarks of prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by pastor
Doug Batchelor landmarks of prophecy as
a video Bible study adventure designed
for today's audiences presenting the
landmark themes of the Bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your epic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of prophecy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWF Axio
RG and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 pack so our ji did you
enjoy this program make sure to tell
your family and friends tune in next
time for more Bible answers live honest
and accurate answers to your Bible
questions
[Music]